i know so many conservatives who say uh
the war on drugs
failed i don't even know what that
statement means we put a lot of drug
dealers in prison doesn't sound like
that failed to me sounds like it worked
pretty well
well people still do drugs yeah of
course they do people are still gonna we
have a laws against murder people are
still gonna commit murders the point is
you wanna
punish these things and try to control
these things
but that that system has been flipped
including on murder by the way
la and this is shocking even to me
i know how left-wing la gets but
the la district attorney already was a
huge liberal
and that lada lost to an even more
radical person
george gascon i don't even know how to
pronounce his name
who is running on a platform and who won
on a platform basically of springing
some of the worst prisoners from the
clink so
he recently was approached while he was
giving a little talk he was approached
by the mother of joshua rodriguez
who was kidnapped tortured and murdered
in 2015
and recently special circumstances were
filed on the accused killers those will
be dropped under gascon's new policy
which will take life without parole
off the table so the killers will not
seriously be punished
for what they did and this mother walks
up to this new d.a and starts pleading
with him yelling at him
listen to the arrogance listen to the
contempt
in this jerk's voice i apologize you
know it's unfortunate that we have
people that do not have enough education
to keep their mulch out for a moment so
we can talk
uh but anyway my son could never speak
again
because he was murdered he was kidnapped
tortured and murdered to communicate
with you
my son matters
tortured him what are you gonna do about
it nothing yeah
[Music]
he's just he doesn't need to hear this
what does he care
this guy gascon is cartoonishly
villainous
can you imagine a grieving mother saying
these people
murdered my son and you're gonna let
them get off the hook basically or
you're gonna
let them have a much less severe
punishment and he turns to her
with pure disdain and he says i'm sorry
that some people are not
educated enough to keep to no one to
keep their mouth shut
so that i can talk this guy is
particularly
visibly villainous this is how
every single one of these establishment
elites thinks about the rest of their
countrymen
they might not say it they might have
slightly better political sense than to
say that
but that is what they think i think
why are these little plebeians why are
they
oh your murdered son oh what you think
you should be
the killers should be punished you just
don't have as brilliant
and broad a mind as i have to understand
that actually
the killers they're victims of a system
and you just don't you're too
you're too close you're too emotional
you frivolous woman
you're not educated like me
you i don't care about your pleading
that's what they think that's what
they've thought about us from the
beginning by the way
with this lockdown isn't it we say you
know
our family members are dying alone for
absolutely no reason we're not allowed
to have funerals we
haven't been able to see them we can't
live you've taken our livelihoods from
us you've taken our life savings from us
you won't give us any
even any sort of stimulus not any
significant stimulus to
stay afloat we're losing everything over
here and what do the public health
experts say they basically say
gosh some people are not educated enough
to know when to keep their mouth shuts
and let dr
fauci talk or dr scarf talk even though
we don't believe what we're saying
we don't believe it for us but we
believe it for you you all need to stay
locked down and lose your livelihoods
so that you know we're going to commute
on zoom we're going to go to our beach
houses
no big deal that's a hierarchy
dr scarf and dr fauci and pelosi and
gavin newsom at the french laundry
and cuomo and all these guys they get to
do things that the rest of americans
don't get to do
because they're in a special privileged
class and
according to the left there ought to be
special privileged classes
and if you're a member of a special
privilege class you get you get to go to
the beach house and you get to have
thanksgiving
and you get the vaccine first and
that's it you deserve it and you know
they'll just pay lip service to
historical injustice oppression
uh i don't know whatever the buzzword is
that's intersectionality that
and that's why there's really no
argument there
it's because they're in the class and
you're not in the class
[Music]
you